in this video we're going to introduce
ourselves to the idea of negative
numbers
now you're already used to the idea of
positive numbers you just called them
numbers not positive numbers and just to
give you an example i will draw a number
line here and this should all be review
for you
so
let me start at 0
and then this would be
1
this would be 2
this would be 3.
and you can think of these numbers which
you're used to which we could call
positive numbers is how far we are above
zero one is one above zero two is two
above zero
now what do you think negative numbers
are going to be if positive numbers are
how far we are above zero then a
negative number would be how far are we
below zero
so for example if i go one to the left
on this number line that would now get
us to negative one positive one is one
to the right negative one is one to the
left if i were to go another one to the
left i would get to negative two and i
could keep going as many positive
numbers are there are i can have the
negative version of it however far i am
to the right i could be that far to the
left
now some of you especially if you live
in very cold parts of the world might
have already experienced negative
numbers in some way for example if you
look at a thermometer and this has both
a cent a celsius thermometer right over
here and fahrenheit
we know that you can get temperatures
below zero degrees celsius and
temperatures below zero degrees
fahrenheit on this thermometer they just
mark the how far we are below zero with
these red numbers but really these are
negative numbers and we specify negative
numbers by putting that negative sign
right in front of it
like that
so for example 20 degrees celsius is
positive 20 degrees celsius is actually
a pretty comfortable temperature
but negative 20 degrees celsius that is
below 20 degrees celsius below the
freezing point of water that is a very
very very very cold temperature one is
20 degrees above zero one is 20 degrees
below zero
so big picture for any given number
there's a negative version of it for
example this right over here would be
positive six
and then you could have negative six
but negative 6 is 6 below 0 or 6 left of
the 0 on the number line while positive
6 is of course 6 above 0.
so i will leave you there you might be
thinking oh wow this looks a lot like a
subtraction sign maybe it is related to
subtraction somehow or how can i do
addition and subtraction multiplication
and division with negative numbers and
for that we will go to future videos